[Musique]
bonjour à tous est ravie de vous
retrouver sur public sénat le projet de
loi organisant la sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire prévue le 10 juillet
prochain était débattu hier au sénat et
selon les sénateurs et bien le texte
permettait au gouvernement de conserver
un état d'urgence qui ne disait pas son
nom avec des prérogatives qui portait
atteinte aux libertés publiques et
individuelles
les sénateurs ont donc modifié le projet
de loi avant de le voter
je vous propose de regarder la science
mis en place le 23 mars l'état d'urgence
sanitaire avait méthodiquement organisé
le placement en quarantaine de nos
libertés individuelles fondamentales et
politique face à la crise liée aux covit
19 nous avions accepté cet état de fait
tout en dénonçant les possibles dérives
d'un tel droit d'exception foncé est las
de constater que nos craintes étaient
fondées alors que le gouvernement
s'apprête à mettre fin à l'état
d'urgence sanitaire le 10 juillet il
estime également nécessaire de
s'approprier
certains de ces outils jusqu'au 30
octobre
si cet article est était adoptée en cas
d'un risque nouveau de propagation du
virus
le premier me c'est le préfet se verrait
notamment attribué le droit de réguler
la circulation des individus d'aménager
le fonctionnement des établissements
recevant du public et surtout de
réglementer la tenue des rassemblements
une telle volonté est incompréhensible
si l'exécutif demande la fin de l'état
d'urgence c'est qu'il estime que la
crise sanitaire est sous contrôle
pour quelle raison alors souhaité il
entraver la capacité de nos concitoyens
à se réunir et à manifester entre droit
d'exception et droit commun le
gouvernement veut désormais défi définir
une troisième voie transitoire ou le
premier se fonderait dans le second une
telle situation n'est pas souhaitable
avec la fin de l'urgence sanitaire
devrait arriver le déconfinement de nos
droits et libertés l'exécutive ne
saurait se livrer à une gouvernance
solitaire par le décret venant restreint
et réguler nos moindres faits et gestes
je vous la mer
merci chers collègues la parole et au
président bruno retailleau
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre on arrive à l'article 1er qui
est l'article le plus important de ce
texte de loi est monsieur mini je
voudrais prendre quelques minutes
seulement pour bien vous expliquer
l'état d'esprit dans lequel nous sommes
d'abord nous avons souhaité soutenir les
deux premiers textes qui consacrait cet
état d'urgence sanitaire dans leurs
dimensions juridiques tels cas pour le
23 mai puis deux mois plus tard la
prolongation nous n'avons pas ni négocié
ni mesurer notre soutien au gouvernement
dans la mesure où nous pensions c'était
notre ligne que notre devoir au sénat ou
au parlement était de donner au
gouvernement à l'exécutif
les moyens nécessaires d'assumer sa
mission
sa mission étant en cas de crise
sanitaire évidemment la protection des
français et donc nous avons voté
j'allais dire presque les yeux fermés ou
presque
les deux textes sur l'état d'urgence il
aura fallu pour ce texte là toute la
subtilité de notre président de la
commission des lois et les groupes toute
la détermination des commissaires de
cette même commission des lois elle
n'est pas moins importante pour trouver
un chemin qui pour ne pas être nouveau
était très étroit pour ne pas rejeter le
texte
très franchement lorsque nous avons vu
le titre évidemment le titre est
savoureux unis même sucre et la sortie
d'état d'urgence mais qu' on a constaté
que il s'agissait simplement prolongé de
quatre mois des dispositifs qui avait
cours en matière de contraintes à la
liberté de circulation de rassemblement
et cetera
évidemment nous pensons et c'est notre
analyse que ce que vous demandez à la
représentation nationale excède ce que
nécessite l'état sanitaire actuelle il y
aura jean termine par là une singularité
française qui conviendra d'étudier pas
ce soir nous avons eu le confinement le
plus rugueux le plus dur le plus long
nous avons eu sans doute toutes les
économies occidentales européennes
l'arrêt le plus brutal et enfin nous
avons eu un état de droit parmi les plus
contraint le parlement a travaillé de
façon difficile la justice est presque
interrompue et il ya eu un transfert un
transfert massif des pouvoirs vis-à-vis
de l'exécutif
ce que je suis ce que je veux simplement
vous dire c'est que le sénat malgré
toute sa bonne volonté a profondément
amendé le texte pour faire en sorte que
l'on puisse proportionnée les pouvoirs
qui sont attribués à l'exécutif et
notamment premier ministre à l'état réel
de d'urgence sanitaire mais que nous
sommes arrivés à la vraiment la limite
de nos possibilités de souplesse et pour
accepter des dispositifs qui seront plus
grand talent je veux le dire pour
éclairer les choses et notre assemblée
parce que faudra pas compter sur nous et
j'en termine par là pour que en cmp on
puisse aller bien au-delà de ce que on
peut faire ce soir est ce que la
commission des lois fait merci chers
collègues donc nous autres nous entamons
cet article avec trois amendements
identiques le 13 le 15 et le 17 le xiii
c'est
le président caennais oui merci monsieur
bridant mach ministre le président de la
commission des lois le 23 mars nous
avons eu un texte premier texte sur
l'état d'urgence adoptées dans les
conditions d'urgence que nous savons et
à l'époque j'ai relu déclaration en
général j'avais évoqué la notion d'
article 16 rampant à caractère sanitaire
je ne pensais pas avoir si bien dit
monsieur le ministre et le en même temps
est tout à la fois que vous nous
proposez ne convient pas c'est pour ça
que le groupe socialiste et républicain
demande le supprimer purement et
simplement cet article nous pensions
sortir de l'état d'exception mais la
lecture de ce texte que vous nous
proposez quelle déception
être ou ne pas être
l'état d'urgence est en vigueur ou ne yo
n'est pas un état d'urgence on le
déclare on lève l'état d'urgence est
déclaré si les conditions
exceptionnelles défini par la loi sont
réunis puis levée si elles ne le sont
plus c'est le noir blanc blanc ou noir
ce n'est pas gris ou si c'est flou
connaissez la suite
une sortie d'état d'urgence ne
s'organise pas monsieur le ministre
elle ne s'aménage pas elle ne se décline
pas l'état d'urgence se lève dans sa
totalité pour mettre fin à l'exception
et le droit commun deviendra et doit
devenir la règle tout cas c'est comme ça
que tous les bons juristes voient la fin
d'une situation à caractère exceptionnel
avec ce texte vous maintenez finalement
l'état d'urgence dans sa substance tout
en consentant à sortir formellement du
cadre de la loi du 23 mars 2020 pour une
durée de 4 mois minimum et
potentiellement donc indéterminée il ya
là une contradiction vous estimez que le
maintien des pouvoirs exorbitants et
nécessaire nous nous pensions que s'il y
a levé l'état d'urgence
il n'y a pas d'étapes d'exception il n'y
a pas de pouvoirs exorbitants même pour
le premier ministre ou ses ministres
c'est notre position monsieur le
ministre la thérapie tout à l'heure par
le président jean pierre sueur qui a été
très clair vous lever l'état d'urgence
et vous lever à 100%
si vous avez besoin de redéfinir un état
d'urgence
eh bien nous serons à vos côtés si les
clusters augmente si la pandémie reprend
nous serons à vos côtés pour revenir
vers un état protégeant les français
mais ce que vous nous proposez est un
milieu de chemins qui ne nous convient
pas et donc nous demandons la
suppression pure et simple de cette
digue premier merci chers collègues 15
le président ça si oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président la
commission des lois
nous partageons avec vous le constat de
l'ambiguïté de ce texte de fin d' état
d'urgence sanitaire qui en fait n'en est
pas une
vous avez annoncé à la presse monsieur
bac vous ne propose ne riez pas je vous
cite au sénat d'adopter telle quelle un
texte qui est profondément ambigu vous
avez même indiqué je poursuis je dis
attention ou bien on sort de l'état
d'urgence et alors on en sort vraiment
ou bien on irait ce n'est alors il faut
le dire fin de citation les
modifications que vous avez proposé
effet voté par la majorité de la
commission des lois ne permettent pas
selon nous de sortir de l'ambiguïté que
vous dénoncez puisqu'elles sont elles
mêmes en bis q vous proposer par exemple
n'ont plus de permettre l'interdiction
de manifestation mais leur
réglementation
alors vous savez comme moi que la
réglementation et nous pouvons faire
confiance à un préfet comme monsieur
l'allemand ce domaine peut entraîner une
dissuasion forte
l'excès de réglementation pourra bien
entendu masquer une forme d'interdiction
comme vous l'indiquiez où vous sommes
dans l'état d'urgence ou alors vous ne
le sommes pas
l'attitude l'attitude claire courageuse
pour faire respecter les libertés
publiques et les pouvoirs du parlement
et celle du rejet de ce texte est tout
parler particulièrement de cet article
1er comment ne pas douter que la
prolongation de mesures d'exception et
le texte de la commission s'inscrit
malgré tout dans ce cadre jusqu'au 30
octobre
diminue encore par rapport à l'état
d'urgence sanitaire classique ou
d'exception le pouvoir d'intervention
des parlementaires députés et sénateurs
enfin j'y faisais allusion nous
constatons clairement les pouvoirs
exorbitants conviés au préfet en matière
de libertés publiques notamment avec les
alinéas 7 à 9 de cet article est donc
pour toutes ces raisons nous vous
proposons vous également de supprimer
cet article
merci chers collègues le 17 monsieur
l'abbé oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement propose comme les
précédents de supprimer l'article
premier du projet de loi
en effet cet article prolonge des
mesures restrictives de liberté
fondamentale et de droit mis en place
dans le cadre de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et vient ainsi brouiller la
frontière entre l'exception et le droit
commun avec des risques avec les risques
que cela comporte pour l'état de droit
alors que la population est appelée à
voter pour le second tour des
municipales que les activités
économiques reprennent et c'est tant
mieux et que la situation sanitaire
continue de s'améliorer et c'est tant
mieux
la proposition du gouvernement de créer
ce nouveau régime dérogatoire est à la
fois disproportionnée et inutile en
effet le droit existant cela a déjà été
expliqué à plusieurs reprises lors de
nos débats est largement suffisant pour
gérer la situation sanitaire et en cas
de résurgence de l'épidémie le
gouvernement et le parlement seraient en
capacité de prendre les mesures
nécessaires et cela en urgence certes et
cela a été souligné la commission des
lois à limiter fortement la portée de
cet article en proposant de donner au
premier ministre le pouvoir de
réglementer plutôt que d'interdire
cela atténue indéniablement les
restrictions de liberté proposé par le
texte
mais c'est malgré tout même si les
casinos quasiment vidée de sa substance
un nouveau régime dérogatoire au droit
commun qui nous est proposé et c'est de
ce fait un entre deux pour nous il utile
de plus le contexte actuel doit nous
amener à être plus que vigilants sur la
question de restrictions apportées aux
libertés je pense en particulier au
droit de manifestation
rappelons que le conseil d'état a
considéré la limitation de ce droit
fondamental prises dans le cadre de
l'état d'urgence comme une atteinte
grave et manifestement illégale à la
liberté de réunion et à la liberté de
manifester
et ce alors que après plusieurs mois de
limitations de leur liberté public et à
l'heure où s'organisent les débats sur
le monde d'après les citoyens ressentent
légitimement le besoin de s'exprimer
collectivement leurs idées et cela en
toute liberté
je vous remercie merci cher collègue
monsieur rapportant l'avis de la
commission
mais monsieur le président tous ses
amendements
je les aurais très bien compris si
c'était appliqué aux textes qui nous
viennent de l'assemblée nationale ce
texte la commission des lois la
supprimer elle en a adopté un autre
toutes les mesures qui étaient recopier
exactement et à la virgule près du
régime de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
mesures concernant la liberté d'aller et
venir mesures concernant la fermeture
d'établissements recevant du public
mesures concernant enfin d'autres
libertés aussi essentiel que la liberté
de manifester ou la liberté de réunion
ont été purement et simplement retirée
du texte par la commission des lois
elle a intégralement réécrit ces
dispositions parce que je n'aurais n'y a
rien des propos que j'ai tenus cher
présidente à ceux ci en effet et je leur
ai dit tout à l'heure à la tribune je
considère que un texte de sortie de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire qui reproduit
les mesures les plus importantes de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire est un texte
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et je veux bien admettre que
si nous sommes réellement comme l'a
indiqué le gouvernement dans un texte
sur la sortie de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire alors il ne faut prendre que
des mesures qui sont utiles pour la
sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
et c'est ce que je crois nous avons fait
en
réduisant le champ des mesures qui nous
était proposé j'espère d'ailleurs que le
gouvernement se ralliera à la
proposition de la commission des lois
si vous l'adoptez parce que nous lui
permettons de faire ce qui est encore
nécessaire pour les boîtes de nuit pour
permettre de d'imposer qu'on porte le
masque dans les métros des grandes
villes qui sont des choses à mon avis
assez raisonnable pour lesquels il faut
quand même une base légale mais nous ne
voulons rien de plus que cela alors je
ne veux pas vous demander de retirer vos
amendements
ils sont pour vous le moyen de marquer
très clairement une position politique
mais moi j'essaye d'être pragmatique et
d'apporter des réponses je crois que
c'est notre rôle à nous sénateurs de ne
pas avoir une position qui soit
exclusivement une position politique
mais de chercher des solutions qui
n'exposent pas à les libertés
individuelles et les libertés publiques
à des restrictions aussi vaste que celle
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
mais qui permettent tout de même pendant
une période qui est encore incertaine
d'appliquer dans l'intérêt général dans
l'intérêt de la santé publique
des précautions qui reste utile et bien
entendu s'il fallait faire des des
mesures plus importantes alors le
gouvernement pourrait toujours recourir
à l'état d'urgence sanitaire
et donc je crois que nous sommes sur la
piste d'atterrissage et je vous convie à
que parce que nous nous réunissions sur
cette solution qui me paraît pratique et
très respecté liberté parce que je le
sais bien et vous avez raison de le dire
c'est notre vocation à nous sénat
d'affirmer dans la discussion
parlementaire la préoccupation des
libertés en même temps que celle de la
santé merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur ministre
personne ne peut dire mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs que le virus a
disparu de notre pays et personne ne le
dit personne ne peut donc considérer
qu'il faille aujourd'hui nous départir
d'outils dont j'avais retenu les
précédents débats qu'il vous paraît
c'est à vous même qui avez rédigé ces
amendements de suppression indispensable
dans la lutte contre la diffusion du
virus
je vous donnerai un exemple si vous
votez cette suppression de l'article 1 à
la minute où l'état d'urgence s'arrête
il n'y aura plus aucune base légale pour
imposer le port du masque dans le métro
j'avais cru comprendre de récents
échanges renouvelés au sénat y compris
de la part des sénateurs et sénatrices
des groupes qui y sont signataires de
cet amendement dont je ne critique pas
la légitimité ne me revient pas de le
faire
j'avais cru comprendre que le port du
masque était une notion qui de grande
sensibilité pour les sénateurs et les
sénatrices que vous êtes
j'avais cru comprendre monsieur le
sénateur qui est bien certain nombre de
débats pour savoir si oui ou non nous
devrions imposer le port du masque dans
la sphère publique sur tous les bancs
sur tous les bancs et dans tous les
partis
donc aujourd'hui je vous demande de
permettre aux gouvernements de continuer
de rendre obligatoire le port du masque
dans certains dans certaines situations
comme par exemple le métro je vous
demande aussi autre chose le
gouvernement vous demande aussi autre
chose de nous donner la base légale pour
interdire le rassemblement de 40000
personnes les unes à côté des autres
dans un stade ou dans un lieu fermé
j'ai cru comprendre aussi là aussi y
compris d'ailleurs je regardais twitter
ce que je n'ai pas fait la fête de la
musique
j'aurais adoré la faire mais je
regardais twitter hier j'ai vu beaucoup
de commentaires face aux scènes de
liesse populaire qu'on voyait notamment
dans la capitale française monsieur le
sénateur et certaines villes
les mesures de restrictions ont été
appliquées peut-être avec plus de brefs
et je voyais sur les i sur les
commentaires à nouveau chez des élus de
tous bords que des gens s'étonnait de
voir
quelques centaines de personnes
dansaient les unes contre les autres
dehors en plein air si le dispositif
tombe il n'y a plus aucune base légale
pour interdire le rassemblement de
milliers de milliers de personnes y
compris dans des lieux clos dont on sait
par expérience que c'est quand même une
condition absolument propice à la
circulation du virus
et puis on a eu des débats à la fois
intéressant et tout à fait nécessaire
sur la question de l'outre-mer des outre
mer lors des précédentes occasions que
j'ai eues de me présenter devant vous où
il était question de toutes les mesures
de précaution que nous devions prendre à
l'égard des territoires ultramarins à
l'heure à laquelle je vous parle le
facteur de reproduction du virus
d'incidence le nombre de positivité des
tests en guyane sont des paramètres de
vives inquiétudes et qui nous mobilise
et bien écoutez si vous votez cet
article un jeune aurait pu demain de
base légale pour réguler les flux
d'avion entre la métropole et la guyane
pour assurer des contrôles de tests de
dépistage ou d'isolement des personnes
qui arrivent de territoire même des
territoires étrangers prenez le brésil
par exemple où la circulation du virus y
est important n'aurait pu de base légale
donc j'aurai deux possibilités où je dis
aux français je n'ai plus la base légale
je n'ai pas eu la confiance des
parlements pour pouvoir continuer de
mettre en mesure de mettre des mesures
de restriction des libertés a juste et
adaptée la situation où nous prenons un
décret et autant de décret qui n'en faut
moi je suis ancien parlementaire et je
considère je considère que le respect
des règles démocratiques nécessite d'en
passer par le parlement est de
recueillir la confiance du parlement et
la voie du décret qui tue le voit sans
doute plus rapide
ce n'est pas la voie que le gouvernement
a retenu j'entends toutes les critiques
et je m'en excuse
au nom du gouvernement sur les délais
contraints monsieur le président que
vous avez eu une fois de plus pour
examiner ce texte sur les conditions de
réunion du parlement je le sais croyez
moi je passe plus qu'à mon tour un
certain nombre d'heures de journée et
parfois de nuit sur les bancs et de
l'assemblée et du sénat et je sais votre
diligence et je sais votre implication
et le sérieux du travail que vous que
vous réalisez et je crois pas au fond
que nous soyons ici dans un débat
partisan politique au sens du terme
parce que le virus n'a pas de parti
parce que les moyens de lutter contre
lui n'ont pas de partie et parce que
j'ai toujours cru en moi et je le crois
toujours que l'unité nationale dans une
période d'épidémie comme celle que nous
traversons est aussi un signal que nous
envoyons aux français de responsabilité
collective bref
je donne un avis défavorable aux
amendements de suppression de l'article
2 1 tout en soulignant les travaux qui
ont été réalisés en commission un
certain nombre d'entre eux sont
peut-être susceptible d'obtenir des
situations d'accord en cmp je ne sais
pas je ne siège pas en cmp il ne me
revient pas de le dire mais je salue le
sérieux des travaux et l'esprit avec
lequel la commission des lois a
travaillé ce texte
merci monsieur ministre madame cohen
pour explication de vote sur et monsieur
le ministre il ne nous a pas échappé
qu'on examinait le texte delà de la
commission des lois est pas le texte du
gouvernement mais ça ne nous empêche
quand même pas de d'apporter des
critiques sur le texte du du
gouvernement et je suis désolé je suis
désolé quand même monsieur le ministre
mais quand vous parlez des masques et de
l'obligation du port du masque fin quand
même y compris dans cet hémicycle là il
ya eu un moment alors certainement parce
que c'était un moment de connaissances
sur sur ce virus ou finalement y compris
vous vous n'étiez pas convaincu de la
validité du port du masque donc je crois
qu'il faut pas mélanger les genres vous
êtes en train de parler de sujets qui ne
sont pas les sujets dont on parle de
quoi s'agit-il quand même dans votre
texte monsieur le ministre
ça peut vous contrarier ça peut vous
irriter il faut que vous entendiez les
critiques vous voulez passer finalement
de manifestations libres qui doivent
être déclarés c'est la loi ad à des à
des manifestations qui doivent être
maintenant autorisés et c'est ça le
problème
c'est à dire que finalement là on arrive
sur des choses qui sont liberticides et
vous êtes en train de nous parler des
masses que vous êtes en train de vous
parler de la situation en guyane et
monsieur le ministre
enfin il ya des collègues ici qui
connaissent beaucoup mieux la situation
moi même parce que je je sais que tout
le monde ne peut pas maîtriser les
choses mais vous monsieur le ministre
vous savez très bien quand même quelle
est la situation en guyane et qu'elles
sont vous les entendez les appels au
secours de nos collègues de guyane et
des territoires ultramarins sur le
manque de masquer le manque
d'équipements le besoin de médecins le
manque d'hôpitaux
alors ne mélangez pas les
les genres et s'il nous convainquent sur
quelque chose que vous portez et que
vous devez assumer
merci cher collègue monsieur
bonnecarrère pour explications de vote
le président chacune et chacun est
attentif à l'efficacité de notre société
dans la lutte contre la pandémie il n'ya
aucun débat là dessus
est ce que cela passe obligatoirement
par un texte supplémentaire
c'est ça notre débat sur la question du
maintien ou pas de l'article 1
et pour répondre à cette question il
faut savoir quels sont les moyens dont
disposent actuellement de l'exécutif qui
sont à notre sens les moyens
traditionnels de l'exécutif mais aussi
les moyens qui lui ont été données par
la loi du 23 mars
non pas la loi en ce qu'elle a donné son
accord sur l'état d'urgence mais en ce
qu'elle a prévu les modalités
transitoire les modalités poste est à
d'urgence et dans ses modalités post
état d'urgence
l'article 3131 1 du code de la santé
publique vous a donné pour cette période
les mêmes moyens
tous les moyens de 3130 30 15 donc pour
en tout cas une majorité parties une
partie importante des représentants du
groupe centriste
vous avez tous les moyens de prendre les
décisions utiles face au risque d'un
retour de la pandémie
il n'est pas nécessaire de l'untec
supplémentaires et en particulier
lorsque je prends la question du port du
masque gelé au petit en réglementer les
moyens de transport ou lorsque vous
évoquez monsieur le ministre les
rassemblements et bien c'est une
modalité que je n'ai que j'ai à l'alinéa
6 exprimé autrement
est ce que je peux vous poser la
question en sens inverse
vous nous avez dit que vous aviez besoin
du texte pour interdire les
rassemblements si c'était nécessaire
pour les problèmes de déplacements
aériens pour les problèmes de port de
masques dites moi en fonction de votre
raisonnement
dans quelles circonstances vous seriez
amené à demander au parlement
le prononcé de l'état d'urgence et quels
seraient les moyens supplémentaires que
vous donnerez cet état d'urgence
à mon avis il explose et que vous ne
nous faire montre que la réponse est non
et que effectivement vous nous demandez
un état d'urgence qui qui n'en porte pas
le nom ce qui n'est pas bon pour la
clarté de la situation dans notre
société et qui pour une partie d'entre
nous n'est pas nécessaire merci cher
collègue monsieur ferro pour explication
de vote
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre j'ai été un peu surpris des
explications qui comme élu parisien me
conduisent plutôt à trouver que votre
votre propos illustrent il ya quelque
chose qui ne va pas vous avez parlé de
la fête de la musique hier pas cité de
communes enfin j'imagine que les images
auxquelles vous faisiez allusion sont à
paris ce même dans l'arrondissement où
je suis élue mais il ne s'agit pas
d'arrêter d'autorisation de la maire de
paris sur des manifestations spontanées
il s'agit du pouvoir de police du préfet
de police qui alors que nous sommes en
état d'urgence n'a pas estimé devoir
interdire la préfet la fête de la
musique totalement et je ne le conteste
et je ne conteste pas qui va les polices
et est par ailleurs présente pour faire
son travail ensuite mais c'est bien la
preuve que nous sommes en état d'urgence
et pourtant il ya eu des rassemblements
spontanés qui ont pris trop d'ampleur
dans la situation de crise sanitaire
dans laquelle nous sommes
de même que lorsque en ile de france il
s'est agi de l'ouverture des parcs et
jardins au période d'état d'urgence
là vous n'avez pas fait confiance aux
élus locaux et vous avez vous les avez
obligé à fermer pendant une période qui
s'est avéré beaucoup trop longue
de l'avis général donc je pense que le
prolongement des mesures inscrites dans
l'état d'urgence dans une loi qui le
prolonge ne sont pas adaptées aux
situations que nous connaissons et nous
l'avons bien vu notamment à paris en ile
de france c'est particulièrement vrai en
milieu urbain dense par rapport aux
enjeux auxquels nous avons
en face merci chers collègues donc je
vais mettre aux voix ces trois
amendements j'ai été saisi d'une demande
de scrutin public par la commission des
lois sur les amendements de 13 15 et 17
je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable celui du
gouvernement aussi rivette procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par atik 5 6 du règlement le
scrutin est ouvert
nombre de votants 319 suffrages exprimés
315% contre 215
le sénat n'a pas adopté nous poursuivons
avec deux amendements identiques le 18
madame n bassar et monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le dimanche 14 juin le chef de l'état
emmanuel macron nous annoncer que
l'ensemble de la france métropolitaine
passer en zone verte sur le plan
sanitaire
nous accueillons avec soulagement mais
plus dans cette nouvelle qui laissait
présager un prochain retour à la normale
dans ces conditions il semble légitime
que l'état d'urgence sanitaire
institué par la loi du 23 mars 2020
prenne fin nous tenons donc à pointer du
doigt l'incohérence du gouvernement qui
souhaite ici clé un droit hybride entre
le droit commun et le droit d'exception
en vigueur pendant l'épidémie
monsieur le ministre si vous estimez que
la pandémie est suffisamment sous
contrôle pour que nous puissions nous
passer de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
agissez en conséquence que des
réglementations soient conserve un an
notamment en matière de port du masque
ou de respect des gestes barrières dans
les transports en commun nous
l'entendons parfaitement ses propres ces
précautions nous semble parfaitement
raisonnable mais il nous paraît excessif
de conférer ses prérogatives au premier
ministre une telle mesure attentatoire à
l'article 13 de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et discutaient du
citoyen
sur la liberté de circulation est
disproportionnée à l'heure où l'exécutif
soit souhaite assurer une transition
vers la fin de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
ainsi le présent amendement de menti la
suppression de l'alinéa 2 de l'article 1
le virus est toujours présent mais
l'attend nous sommes donc favorables à
ce que des précautions soit de mise mais
sans disproportion
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
ministre la mono en 23 ans discussion
commune c'est un amendement du
gouvernement qui vise à préciser la
portée des notions retenu au premier
alinéa de l'article 1 à l'issue des
travaux de la commission des lois la
faculté général de réglementer la
circulation des personnes et des
véhicules doit permettre d'intégrer le
cas échéant des mesures de restriction
de la circulation des personnes ou des
véhicules
au delà d'un certain périmètre
géographique sans donner pour autant la
possibilité de prendre des mesures
assimilables à des interdictions de
sortie du domicile comme le prévoyait
l'état d'urgence sanitaire c'est ce qui
permettrait d'ailleurs en cas de cluster
eau plus largement au cas du début il y
avait un début de résurgence de
l'épidémie de limiter la circulation au
delà d'une zone par exemple d'une ville
comme ça a été fait dans beaucoup de
pays encore cette semaine d'ailleurs
dans un certain nombre de pays dans le
monde qui ont été amenés à limiter la
circulation en dehors de villes dans
lesquelles il y avait une résurgence du
virus c'est ce qui permet d'imaginer
qu'ils aient un classeur avec une
dissémination communautaire du virus au
sein d'une commune ou d'une
intercommunalité
c'est ce qui permettrait de limiter les
sorties de seat de cette
intercommunalité pour éviter la
diffusion non contrôlables du virus
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur sur ces deux amendements me
suis heureux de constater que la
position de la commission est une
position médiane puisque la position est
défavorable aux deux amendements en
ayant adopté une proposition qui permet
de calibrer exactement les mesures
susceptibles d'être prises dans la
sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire non
madame benbassa le texte de la
commission n'est pas contraire à une
liberté fondamentale proclamé dans la
déclaration
des droits de l'homme et non monsieur le
ministre nous ne souhaitons pas vous
permettre de faire plus que réglementer
les circulations de nos compatriotes
vous voulez la restreindre
nous voulons que vous puissiez imposer
le port du masque dans le métro c'est
une chose certaine
mais nous ne voulons pas que vous
puissiez en réalité interdire un certain
nombre de déplacements
si vous deviez le faire vous pourrez
toujours prendre un décret pour déclarer
l'état d'urgence sanitaire même si vous
n'utilisez pas tout les toutes les
potentialités
donc avis défavorable aux deux
amendements merci ma cheminée sur le 18
je peux comprendre monsieur le président
les restrictions que vous voulez mettre
et si je devais si nous devions prendre
un décret pour déclarer l'état d'urgence
sanitaire dans tout le pays dès lors
qu'il y aurait un cluster dont nous
aurions peur que la chaîne de
contamination nous échappe parce que
nous ne saurions plus dans la
possibilité de limiter la circulation au
delà d'une zone géographique des
personnes contaminées vous avez c'est
pas le virus qui circulent sont les gens
et les gens qui circulent contaminer la
plupart du temps sans de savoir
d'ailleurs ils sont pour rien mais
circule et circulent c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça que l'épidémie est partie
il ya eu des foyers épidémiques ne
savaient pas qu'ils avaient des foyers
épidémiques
parce que par définition ça ne frappe à
la porte et donc des gens sont
contaminés en grandes quantités et les
gens qui sont partis mais les gens qui
ont quitté des zones et qui on commence
à vous mais les moments des moments où
il peut y avoir la résurgence de cas
épidémique en grand nombre ce qu'on
appelle les clusters et on a la
possibilité de savoir et donc d'être un
capacité d'anticiper je vous ressort le
même exemple un contamines-montjoie
haute-savoie limitation de circulation
fermetures d'écoles contact racing
hospitalisation isolement des gens et on
a évité de prendre la balle si je puis
dire à haute savoie trois semaines ou un
mois plus tôt que le départ d'épidémie
on n'a pas utilisé
je sais pas si vous avez vu que dans les
quatre mois qui viennent de s'écouler
nous aurions pris des mesures de
limitation de circulation des gens qui
seraient abusifs disproportionnée et qui
ciblerait un endroit où des gens en
particulier quel serait le sens de ceux
là quel serait le sens de ceux là
pourquoi vouloir interdire la pour
retirer au gouvernement la possibilité
de limiter temporairement la circulation
en dehors d'une zone d'activités virale
du virus quel usage
considérez vous que nous pourrions avoir
de cette limitation en dehors de la
protection des personnes dans le cas
d'une épidémie avec des mesures urgentes
à prendre
moi je ne j'ai beau creuser même en
étant je me mets à la place de gens qui
aimeraient vraiment pas et qu'ils
considéraient qu on serait vraiment je
n'arrive pas à concevoir
donc je les aurai sur une mesure
temporaire
je n'arrive pas à le concevoir donc
voilà je forcément un avis défavorable
sur l'amendement numéro 18 mai un avis
appuyé sur l'amendement 23 tout en
respectant encore une fois les travaux
faits par la commission au sénat
j'essaye de vous amener parce que c'est
aussi pour ça que vous avez souhaité que
je sois là ce soir pour pouvoir amener
de façon le plus pratique possible les
situations de vie que j'ai rencontrés au
cours des quatre derniers mois et des
décisions que j'ai été amené à prendre
dans l'urgence pour la protection des
personnes
si vous décidez que cet usage a été
abusifs et que vous souhaitez faire en
sorte que la france ne soit plus capable
et que ses représentants ne soit plus
capable de prendre cette décision
encore une fois je suis ici devant le
parlement c'est bien parce que j'accepte
le débat démocratique
je vous le dis juste les conséquences
les conséquences d'un certain nombre de
choses qui peuvent être adoptés par
crainte encore une fois que j'ai du mal
à haïti bée ware ou m ou imagé mais
encore une fois chacun est libre mais
les conséquences potentielles sur notre
arsenal pour lutter contre la diffusion
du virus
imaginez monsieur le rapporteur
président oui je vous remercie monsieur
ministre y est en effet heureux que vous
soyez là pour pouvoir avoir un débat
approfondi sur toutes ces questions
vous dites que vous ne pouvez pas
concevoir ce qui pourrait être une
alternative
limitation de la liberté de circulation
des personnes quand il ya un cluster et
pourtant vous même mis en oeuvre une
politique qui n'a pas pu être mise en
oeuvre au mois de mars
parce qu'elles demandaient des
préparatifs une organisation la
disponibilité de matériel disponibilité
de tests de dépistage et vous savez que
maintenant quand des cas se déclarent
obligatoirement les plateformes qui ont
été mises en place à l'assurance maladie
ils permettent de remonter les filières
de contamination d'identifier les
personnes atteintes de les mettre en 14
n de faire en sorte que indépendamment
de la question de leur autorisation de
circulation ou non ce qui va être
efficace dans la lutte contre la
propagation du virus à une certaine
échelle sans doute ce seront des mesures
alternatives aux restrictions majeur des
libertés publiques que vous avez avec
notre accord fait supporter aux pies
faute de mieux
parce que nous n'avions pas de meilleurs
moyens disponibles est ce que nous
avions les tests de dépistage est ce que
nous avions les masques
est ce que nous avions le système
d'information que nous avons que nous
vous avons autorisé à mettre en place
dans la loi du 11 mai non nous n'avions
rien tout ça maintenant nous l'avons et
nous gardons aussi la possibilité si un
territoire connaît des contaminations
importante d'isoler ce territoire en
établissement dans ce territoire l'état
d'urgence sanitaire c'est d'ailleurs ce
que nous allons faire pour la guyane et
pour mayotte
donc vous avez toute une panoplie tout
un arsenal qui ne vous laisse pas les
mains nues face à des contaminations
locale je crois que c'est de maîtrise de
des contagions vous pouvez l'assuré par
d'autres moyens que des restrictions
majeur aux libertés publiques parce que
la liberté d'aller et venir c'est très
important
étant entendu que naturellement
quelqu'un qui va être qui va accepter de
se mettre en 14ème pour pas contaminer
son milieu de travail dont l'employeur
dira d'ailleurs je ne veux pas vous voir
sur les lieux de travail
tant que vous n'êtes pas rétablie et
bien ça sera ça le moyen efficace
prévenir la contagion donc moi je crois
qu'on peut concevoir une autre politique
que celle que nous avons été condamnés à
accepter faute de mieux
depuis la date du confinement
généralisée des français et qu'il faut
surtout pas se mettre dans l'idée que la
première décision à prendre
quand il y aura des contaminations
quelque part c'est la restrictions aux
libertés
merci à monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
surprise d'en bas ce ne serait en aucun
cas la première décision puisque je
serai dans ce cas-là amené à l'apprendre
50 fois par jour depuis le déconfinement
nous aura pas échappé qu'il ya des
clusters qui sont diagnostiqués tous les
jours
heureusement nous en maîtrisons les
chaînes de contamination et vous aura
pas échappé que nous n'avons pas pro se
procure déclaré d'interdiction mis en
place d'interdiction de circulation
donc nous sommes parfaitement au courant
de cela vous faire remarquer jeu
il ya des choses que je peux partager
messieurs mais c'est le prix normal mais
quand vous dites nous n'avions pas de
masques et de tester pour ça que nous
avons confiné la fête au mieux
raccourcis monsieur le président je
on a cité en exemple un certain nombre
de pays me semble-t-il dans cette
assemblée qui ont tous confinés et
encore je crois que la chine n'est pas
en manque de masques ne l'a jamais été
c'est le premier producteur au monde et
c'est le premier produit lors de tests
je crois avoir lu dans la presse qui a
trois jours que pékin à fermer ses
écoles
arrêtés les avions est interdit les
sorties de la ville bon je dis pas que
la chine est un modèle je dis juste que
permettez-moi permettez-moi cité des
pays que vous avez suffisamment envoyé
en modèle alors singapour si vous
préférez singapour prenez l'allemagne
prenez singapour prenez un certain
nombre de pays qui ont été souvent cité
en modèle ici
excusez moi je enfin on peut pas on peut
pas considérer les choses par le petit
bout de la lorgnette sans considérer
l'ensemble bien
personne n'a envie ici de re confiné et
je peux vous dire que nous mettons tout
en oeuvre pour ne pas être obligé de
recombiner ni un pays ni même une ville
bon bah dessus on est tous d'accord sur
l'objectif mais elle a encore encore de
la taille et de la suite dans les idées
si j'ose dire vous avez été très
nombreux
il nous dira suivez les avis du conseil
scientifique ces scientifiques il nous
dit vous avez besoin d'être encore armés
et oui s'il ya des situations qui
exigent
imaginons une vie que j'ai pas en citer
une parce que dès que je cite une ville
après tout le monde a peur mais
imaginons une ville qu'on va appeler
atlantide dans un coin de la france
magnifique avec des rivières des parcs
et des habitants et imaginons qu'il y
ait un cluster avec une super
contamination et tout d'un coup on
découvre il ya 150 personnes qui sont
malades
imaginez que la population inquiète se
disent oh là là on va quitter la ville
on va partir va prendre et on va prendre
les balises on va remettre ça dans la
voiture va partir imaginez tous les
seuils se passe alors que vous êtes en
train de mettre en place des opérations
de contact racing mais dans ce cas là
attendez jeu on va déclencher l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
becker j'ai entendu sur l'état d'urgence
sanitaire dans cette assemblée j'entends
aujourd'hui qu'il y avait un consensus
avec le travail nous a permis d'avancer
enfin il a fallu quand même y revenir un
certain nombre de fois et c'est tout à
fait naturel encore une fois pardon
pardonnez moi si on déclenche l'état
d'urgence sanitaire dans tout le pays
avec tous les pouvoirs qui vont avec
mais même localement mais même
localement en termes de limitation des
libertés
je ne refait pas l'histoire je ne refait
pas l'histoire le sénateur j'étais
présent je l' ai vécu l'histoire avec
vous monsieur le sénateur le encore une
fois on est ici dans une dans une mesure
que je souhaite ne jamais avoir appliqué
mais que je pourrais être amené à
appliquer parce que si je vous disais
qu'on ne l'appliquera jamais vous seriez
vous ne seriez pas les derniers à me
dire vous n'avez pas anticipé il ya des
pays autour de nous qui ont des confiné
et des pays autour de nous qui tout en
ayant des confiné sont obligés de mettre
temporairement des mesures de limitation
de circulation 100% sans pour autant en
revenir à un état d'urgence sanitaire
voilà je vous ai donné les arguments ses
arguments contre arguments vous allez
voter contre l'amendement du
gouvernement
j'y reviendrai en deuxième lecture parce
que j'y crois mais si j'y croyais pas je
vous dirais écouté il est tard passons à
autre chose je vous dis juste que vous
avez été toujours très vigilant parfois
piquant pour me dire mettez en mesure le
mettez en oeuvre les mesures qui
s'imposent pour protéger les français et
qu'il m'est arrivé un certain nombre de
fois de vous dire que j'avais besoin
d'un certain nombre de mesures et que
vous les avez pas donné je reste
cohérent si monsieur le ministre donc
monsieur le président je vous redonne la
parole mais si ça peut
juste un petit peu court vous savez
qu'avec beaucoup de déférence je suis
toujours vos conseils et que vous avez à
charge de nous faire accoucher texte
j'espère ce soir avant de se coucher est
née en moi c'est le débat et je veux
juste dire deux choses d'abord il y a un
grand pays moderne celui qui a les
meilleurs résultats dans la lutte contre
le coc u19 qui s'appelle la corée du sud
et la corée du sud à maîtriser
l'épidémie sans confinement
je ne veux pas dire ce soit notre modèle
chacun sa culture
néanmois sa atteste de la possibilité
d'obtenir de tels résultats
sans porter atteinte aussi fortement que
nous avons dû le faire et je les dis
nous avons donné notre accord pour le
faire faute de mieux s'en porter
atteinte aux libertés publiques
1° sans précédent dans l'histoire de
notre république est également sans
mettre en péril l'économie un degré tel
que nous attendons tous à une vague de
chômage qui aura des conséquences
sociales et sanitaires liés à la
précarité qui sont l'horizon des
français pour les années à venir
et si vous ministre de la santé vous
considérez qu'il n'y a pas mieux à faire
que le confinement pour faire face à une
reprise de la propagation du virus
alors nous vous disons monsieur le
ministre il ya encore beaucoup de
travail à faire entre vous et nous pour
trouver de meilleures solutions
et encore une fois si vous avez besoin
dans un territoire de porter fortement
atteinte aux libertés publiques
vous avez l'état d'urgence sanitaire on
n'a pas fait pour rien tout de même
et en dehors de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire le conseil constitutionnel ne
vous permettrai pas si vous constatez
vous même que la situation sanitaire dp
du pays ne le justifie pas de prendre
des mesures aussi attentatoire aux
libertés publiques vous avez tout de
même entendu un certain nombre de
signaux forts
nom du conseil d'état comme du conseil
constitutionnel il ya une limite à ce
qu'on peut faire en matière de
restriction des libertés publiques
merci monsieur le président donc mes
chers collègues je mets au voile
amendement 18 avec un double avis
défavorable commission gouvernement qui
et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adoptée je me revois
l'amendement 23 du gouvernement avec un
avis défavorable de la commission qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté deux amendements
discussion commune le 19 madame benbassa
toujours monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues le
présent alinéa 3 confie au premier
ministre la capacité de réglementer le
fonctionnement des établissements
pouvant de recevoir du public
ce pouvoir lui sera attribuée à la fin
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire soit le 10
juillet et jusqu'au 30 octobre
en cas de rebond du nombre de
contaminations liées au corona virus
cette disposition pourrait notamment
être appliquée aux monuments historiques
au lieu de culte et au restaurant une
telle mesure semble disproportionnée et
peu raisonnable au regard de la
conjoncture économique
les secteurs du tourisme et de la
restauration ont été durement impactée
par la crise lyoko vite 19 leurs pertes
s'élèvent aujourd'hui à plusieurs
milliards d'euros
il est donc vital que ces pans de
l'économie puisse le plan d' une
activité normale dans les plus brefs
délais s'il est acceptable par
précaution que de réglementation soit
maintenu quelques temps notamment
matière de recettes et de respect des
gestes barrières
il semble excessive de confier ses
prérogatives au premier ministre
à l'heure où le gouvernement estime
qu'il est temps de mettre un terme à
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
nous appelons l'exécutif à faire preuve
de cohérence
si la situation sanitaire est propice à
ce que l'état d'exception prennent
fin elle est également pour qu'elles
pour que les mesures qu'ils entraient
cessent de s'appliquer
ainsi est il proposé par le présente
amendement de supprimer l'alinéa 3 de
l'article 1 du projet du présent projet
de loi je vous le mercy mercy en
discussion commune le 24 monsieur le
ministre
comme tout à l'heure monsieur président
à linverse le gouvernement souhaite
pouvoir établir la faculté d'ordonner la
fermeture provisoire de certaines
catégories d'établissements recevant du
public tel que prévu dans la rédaction
adoptée par l'assemblée nationale
une telle faculté nécessaires pour
maintenir fermer les établissements
d'une certaine catégorie compte tenu des
risques sanitaires associés au delà du
10 juillet et croyez moi c'est pas de
gaîté de coeur j'ai entendu une
mobilisation cette semaine et je la
comprends
des responsables de lieux de sorties
nocturnes comme les discothèques par
exemple qui aspirent légitimement à
pouvoir vivre de leur activité rouvrir
on sait aussi l'aspiration des français
à pouvoir aller danser et c'est toute la
difficulté mais madame benbassa on peut
considérer que c'est un cas plus de
danger capus de situations à risque etc
en fait tout est formidable
on peut aussi considérer que en fait il
ya des mesures comprend absolument pas
de gaieté de coeur même de toute façon
crève coeur et que nous prenons pas ce
que nous considérons que le risque
inhérent à une autre décision que celle
ci est serait beaucoup trop lourd pour
les français et que pour le coup je vais
citer je vais interpeller monsieur
monsieur le président bas mais l'exemple
qui est cité que vous avez cités
l'accord est d'avoir redire mais vous le
savez que nous n'avons spire entièrement
pas au confinement à que rien dans ce
texte ne nous permet de confiner en
aucune façon le pays en aucune façon et
c'est justement la grande distinction
entre ce texte et l'état d'urgence
sanitaire que nous pouvons plus confiné
avec l'adoption de ce texte
nous ne voulons plus confiné nous ne
confirmons pas nous ne voulons pas bien
je leur dis et je le redirai
l'exemple de la corée du sud la corée du
sud une personne dans des lieux de
sortie nocturne a contaminé plusieurs
dizaines d'autres personnes qui ont
contaminé d'autres personnes et ça fait
repartir une épidémie qui étaient
parfaitement maîtrisés par la corée il
ya des situations qui sont plus à risque
que d'autres
et croyez moi encore une fois c'est ne
voyait aucune volonté d'empêcher les
gens de danser moi même je
j'aime beaucoup surtout qu'on était bien
voir est lancée mais c'est important
c'est important c'est important de
pouvoir le faire c'est important de
pouvoir conserver des mesures et en même
temps accompagnée évidemment les
personnes qui s'occupent des
discothèques pour leur permettre de se
reconvertir en bar de mettre en place un
certain nombre de dispositifs de
spectacle c'est parce qu'il faut pas que
et puis les soutenir financièrement
il est hors de question de laisser les
gens sur le sur le côté chemin
voilà donc cet amendement que je déforme
il est important parce qu'il nous permet
de fermer a priori des lieux
même si l'épidémie s'est relâchée parce
que pour répondre aussi et pardon j'ai
un petit peu long mais il
mais pour répondre aussi à ce que disait
le président serbe a tout à l'heure sur
le fait qu'on peut déclencher un état
d'urgence sanitaire pour déclencher un
état d'urgence sanitaire
il faut qu'une situation de catastrophe
sanitaire je dis la vérité bien une
catastrophe sanitaire
une contamination de 40 personnes dans
une commune n'est pas une catastrophe
sanitaire n'est pas une catastrophe
sanitaire par contre si on attend pour
qu'on ait une catastrophe sanitaire pour
avoir déclenché l'état d'urgence on est
sûr d'y aller on est sur des relais donc
encore une fois mieux vaut prévenir que
guérir d'une doctrine en médecine mais
qui fonctionne plutôt bien
merci monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de
la commission sur ces deux amendements
il est défavorable pour des raisons de
principes qui sont les mêmes que celles
que j'ai développé tout à l'heure pour
les deux amendements
merci monsieur le ministre sur le 19
défavorable monsieur
donc je mets au voile amendement 19 avec
un double avis défavorable commission
gouvernement qui est pour et qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adoptée jeu mais se voit le 24 avec du
gouvernement avec un avis défavorable la
commission qui et pour qui et contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté quatre
amendements discussion commune le 25
monsieur le ministre je profite de
l'occasion
avant de présenter précisément
l'amendement monsieur le président pour
évoquer un point important sur le
quatrième alinéa concernant les
rassemblements et les manifestations le
gouvernement n'a pas déposé des
amendements pour modifier le texte de la
commission
mais les enjeux sont importants et il
importe donc de vérifier que nous en
avons la même compréhension monsieur le
président la commission propose d'écrire
que sans préjudice des articles l 211
tirer d'eux est elle de son ciré 4 du
code de la sécurité intérieure le
premier ministre veut réglementer les
rassemblements de personnes les réunions
et les activités sur la voie publique et
dans les lieux ouverts au public
nous comprenons par là que le premier
ministre pour à réglementer tous les
rassemblements mentionnant mentionné à
ce quatrième alinéa y compris le cas
échéant pour les soumettre n'ont pas
d'autorisation préalable comme c'est
aujourd'hui le cas dans l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
mais une simple déclaration préalable
qui laissera alors aux préfets la
possibilité de les interdire en cas de
troubles graves à l'ordre public au sens
de l'article l 211 tiré 4 qui incluent
les risques sanitaires ainsi que l'a
jugé le conseil d'état dans son
ordonnance du 13 juin dernier
on est d'accord merci alors je vais
présenter maintenant brièvement
l'amendement promis d'être rapide
il s'agit de rétablir la faculté
d'imposer des tests virologiques avant
l'embarquement sous conditions
particulières et de la faculté de
prescrire des mesures de mise en
quarantaine pour les voyageurs arrivant
dans l'hexagone depuis l'outre-mer étant
donné la situation épidémique dans
certains territoires ultramarins croyez
moi je le déplore pour les personnes qui
habitent avoir des mesures de précaution
sur l'entrée pour l'entrée en métropole
me semble de nature à
limiter les risques de reprise epidemics
le territoire métropolitain merci le 5
c'est président ok merci monsieur le
président monsieur le mieux sa collègue
l'article premier à l'est a4 introduire
assemblée nationale vise à imposer aux
personnes qui a séjourné au cours du
mois précédent dans une zone de
circulation de l'infection souhaite
déplacer par transports publics aériens
à destination hexagonal où le haut de
l'une des collectivités main sur les
articles sont nos traders de 112,3 la
constitution de présenter leurs examens
biologiques dépistage ne conduise pas à
une condamnation par le committee ne
nous sont pas favorables à ce que toutes
les mesures soient prises afin de
protéger concitoyens des citoyens qui en
raison de leur situation confins du
territoire national
le tour particulièrement vulnérables
face à risque épidémiologique en
revanche comme l'a présenté notre
collègue stéphane artano qui a inspiré
la banda et qu'il a relevé qu'outre le
salut pour soumettre à bahreïn
territoire avant dans la métropole est
particulièrement discriminées en effet
pour ces derniers il n'existe pas
d'alternative l'avion sur la capacité
actuelle de dépistage il nous craignons
que faute de tests beaucoup relance
alors déplacements cgd entre la liberté
d'aller et venir susceptible de porter
atteinte au secteur touristique
insulaires mais aussi te manque à gagner
pour les compagnies aériennes ainsi
pourquoi nous proposons que celle ci
contribue à l'organisation des tests
propre aux déplacements des tours
dépassement est rien chacun semble y
avoir entre merci chers collègues le 22
monsieur mais non ville merci monsieur
prison monsieur ministre et chers
collègues
cet amendement est un amendement de
précisions il a pour but d'apporter une
clarté supplémentaires au sujet de
l'obligation de présentation de
résultats d'un examen biologique de
dépistage lors du déplacement à
destination en provenance de
notre territoire national d'une part le
dépistage virologique semble le plus
pertinent concernant le caractère
contagieux lé nom me semble me semble le
plus pertinent concernant le le
caractère contagieux d'une personne là
où le test sérologique semble trop
complet moins rapide pour l'utilisation
qui on serait faite dans le cade qui
nous intéresse d'autre part en effet un
voyageur peut être positif à un test
sérologique en étant toutefois plus
contagieux il s'agirait de ne pas
contraindre donc le déplacement des
personnes n'étant plus contagieuse mais
dans les tests conclu à une
contamination donc antérieurs donc ces
deux raisons peuvent avoir une des
conséquence l'eau sur les déplacements
mais également des conséquences
économiques pour nos territoires donc
cet amendement prévoit deux souhaitent
prévoir donc une précision
supplémentaire permettant de simplifier
et de rendre efficace la pratique tout
en gardant bien évidemment à l'esprit
l'enjeu sanitaire merci chers collègues
le 4 c'est monsieur l'abbé monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre chers
collègues
cet amendement est également un
amendement de notre collègue stéphane
artano sénateur de saint pierre et
miquelon
toujours dans la même logique d'adapter
les règles de santé publique aux besoins
des populations les plus vulnérables
cet amendement vise à introduire dans la
loi un engagement du gouvernement qui
consiste à établir un test obligatoire
sept jours après l'arrivée en outre-mer
c'est un dispositif demandé par les
résidents d'outre-mer afin dé terme
d'établir un filtre sanitaires il vise à
remplacer la mesure de 14 n par une
septantaine cette contrainte paraît
nécessaire pour les populations
ultramarines est aussi sensible que le
test imposé avant de prendre l'avion
en réalité le passager de la compagnie
aérienne s'engageraient à faire ces deux
tests au moment de la réservation
les informations apportées à l'assemblée
nationale concernant ce deuxième test ne
leur paraît pas suffisante il ne
s'agirait en effet que de simples
recommandations des préfets pourquoi ne
pas inscrire ce deuxième test dans la
wacom le premier je remercie si monsieur
le rapporteur l'avis de la commission
monsieur le président sur l'amendement
numéro 25 e du gouvernement je dois vous
dire que notre texte celui de la
commission prévoit déjà des mesures et
que celle ci nous paraissaient
suffisantes parce que l'idée qu'on peut
imposer sans distinction entre les
collectivités
il mesure générale de d'obligations de
présenter le résultat d'un examen de
biologie médicale avant de se déplacer
en avion à destination ou en provenance
du territoire métropolitain ou d'une
collectivité d'outre-mer et quand même
rire une rédaction qui est beaucoup trop
large
comprenez que si on ne dit pas que c'est
uniquement applicable à des personnes
venant de zones encore infectés comme si
la règle d'ailleurs pour les quarantaine
pour les mesures d'isolement et comprend
une mesure générale on va retomber sur
les reproches qu'on pu faire un certain
nombre à un certain nombre de
restrictions qui ont été décidées dans
le cadre de l'urgence sanitaire par le
conseil d'état par exemple le conseil
d'état dit vous ne pouvez pas interdire
en général les cérémonies religieuses
vous devez les réglementer pour faire en
sorte qu'elles n'entraînent pas de
contamination
eh bien là c'est la même chose vous ne
pouvez pas imposer une obligation de
test pour tout le monde quand on voyage
entre la métropole et l'outre-mer
vous devez tenir compte des zones encore
affecté alors c'est très intéressant
parce que il y à un arrêté du ministre
de la santé du 22 mai qui met en oeuvre
une disposition de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire sur les zones affectées s'est
arrêté dit que les zones affectées
c'est l'ensemble du territoire national
et du monde
alors évidemment
on peut comprendre quand il ya beaucoup
de contamination mais je crois que cet
arrêté deviendra très rapidement
illégale parce que quand on vous demande
par la loi de déterminer des zones
vous ne pouvez pas dire que c'est tout
le territoire et le monde entier il
faudra déterminer les zones qui sont des
zones dangereuses donc l'avis est
défavorable étant entendu que notre
texte vous permet déjà d'appliquer les
mesures là où c'est nécessaire et par
ailleurs comme c'est le cas pour la
guyane mayotte
vous pourrez pour les pays pour les
régions d'outre-mer où il y à une
situation d'urgence sanitaire
interdire évidemment les déplacements
donc la sécurité sera assurée nous
sommes défavorable à l'amendement 5
rectifié bis de monsieur artano parce
que il met à la charge des compagnies
aériennes le soin de faire respecter
l'obligation de procéder à des tests de
dépistage il me semble que c'est la
responsabilité de l'état et non pas des
compagnies aériennes monsieur mais non
ville dans son amendement numéro 22 pose
une question à laquelle monsieur le
ministre ne suis pas capable de répondre
est votre réponse je la ferai mienne est
ce qu'il faut préciser que le dépistage
dont nous parlons dans nos textes
c'est le dépistage virologiques je n'ai
pas de conviction personnelle sur le
sujet le ministre va répondre oui il
répond oui et donc dans ce cas je donne
un avis favorable à l'amendement de
notre collègue mais non ville et enfin
l'obligation de réaliser un deuxième
test proposé par l'amendement numéro 4
rectifié bis à l'arrivée sur le
territoire nous a paru excessive donc
l'avis est défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre sur les trois
amendements
monsieur le ministre sur les trois
amendements 5,22 et 4 je ne peux être
que favorable à la mode que j'ai
présentées numéro 25 gouvernement même
si l'amendement au 22 présente des
qualités
mais il a pu la porter cet amendement
est moindre que la portée de
l'amendement 25 dont je soutient
l'amendement 25 j'espère que vous serez
nombreux à voter
l'essence est défavorable sur les trois
autres très bien donc je mets aux voix
l'amendement 25 pardon mais c'est magra
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je souscris
parfaitement au propos que vient de
tenir le président de la commission des
lois mais je profite quand même de cet
amendement pour dire un certain nombre
de petites choses personne
je crois que c'est valable pour la
france entière n'a contesté le fait que
le pouvoir de nous confiner était du
ressort du gouvernement
point barre ça ne se discute pas même si
on peut regretter nous ils tram arrête
d'avoir été confinés au moment où nous
n'avions pas encore de cas al'inverse
monsieur le ministre le déconfinement
s'agissant des outre-mer ne peut pas
être appliquée de manière unilatérale
il est absolument indispensable qu'il
soit différenciée collectivités par
collectivité
et quand je dis cela je le dis y compris
entre saint barthélemy et saint martin
même si à 20 km de mer qui nous sépare
parce qu'on ne peut pas nous imposer des
choses qui sont valables à côte qui sont
valables à côté lorsqu'elle ne le sont
plus chez nous j'écoute votre amendement
moi je suis partie à trois jours deux
jours de saint barthélémy à saint martin
on m'a rien demandé ni 'contes ni comme
papy rempli et c'est de saint martin à
pointe à pitre et de pointe à pitre à
paris même chose or si je suis votre
amendement on pourrait très bien me dire
que quand je retourne chez moi la
semaine prochaine eh bien il faut que je
prouve
il faut que j'apporte un test ce que
j'ai l'intention de faire mais qu'en
plus on va me demander de rester chez
moi moi dans quinze jours alors je suis
venu travailler à paris est ce que vous
trouvez ça normal notre part serait il
normal que en impose à des gens qui
viennent dans les territoires de rester
confinés d'avoir des tests et de rester
confinés pendant sept jours
lorsque entre les territoires ultra
marins u même quand je parle de saint
barthélémy pour aller à pointe à pitre à
fort de france
on me pose pas la même chose il ya donc
donc un vrai souci vous ne pouvez pas
traiter le déconfinement de manière
unilatérale vous ne pouvez vous pas
faire autre chose que de le traiter
collectivités par collectivité dans le
cas de saint barthélémy où actuellement
il ne reste que le btp qui travaillent
ce à dire que vous avez créé les
conditions pour couler l'économie
touristique
on ne peut plus on ne peut pas sur 25
kilomètres carrés faire du tourisme
intérieur sera n'a pas de chance on
dépend du tourisme extérieur or vous
dites à un américain qui se rendraient à
saint-barthélemy aujourd'hui qu'il va
venir pendant une semaine qui va rester
15 jours confinés
ça n'a pas de sens donc de grâce
monsieur le ministre et et les
collectivités d'outre-mer de manière
indifférenciée
merci chers collègues donc je mets
sauvoy l'amendement 25 du gouvernement
avec un avis défavorable de la
commission qui et pour qui et contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée jeu mais
je vois l'amendement 5 avec un double
avis défavorable commission gouvernement
qui et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adoptée je mets au voile
amendement 22 avec un avis favorable de
la commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement kg et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté je bezos
voix l'amendement 4 avec un double avis
défavorable qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 20 m'amène bassar
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'alinéa 12 prévoit que le parlement est
informé sans délai des mesures prises
par le gouvernement dans le cadre de la
mise en application de l'article 1er du
présent projet de loi
il est évidemment nécessaire que
l'assemblée nationale le sénat puisse
exercer un suivi des lois votées
nous tenons cependant à a dénoncé par
cet amendement d'appel
l'attitude du gouvernement à l'encontre
du pouvoir législatif
cet alinéa est en effet particulièrement
révélateur du rôle que l'exécutif
souhaite confier au parlement dans le
cadre de la sortie progressive de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
alors que le premier ministre est
habilité à légiférer par décret le
parlement serait lui cantonné à un
simple rôle d'observateur que l'on
informe par courtoisie institutionnels
faut-il rappeler que c'est bien le
gouvernement qui est responsable
politiquement devant le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale et que c'est bien
le parlement qui a pour mission
constitutionnelle de légiférer il n'est
pas acceptable que les chambres soit
ramené un rôle dans le gie cement dans
le gisement et d'habilitation de
l'exécutive à légiférer par ordonnances
ou des clés en conséquence le présent
amendement demandant la suppression de
l'alinéa 12 plus qu'un devoir
d'information envers le parlement le
gouvernement doit lui garantir les
conditions adéquates à l'exercice de ses
fonctions législatives
il est urgent que les élus de la nation
et des territoires retrouvent leur
capacité à édicter les lois je vous
remercie
merci monsieur rapporteurs ont le
commission des lois préfère conserver un
contrôle parlementaire digne de ce nom
elle est donc défavorable à cet
amendement
ainsi monsieur ministre défavorables
aussi donc je mets au voile amendement
20 avec un double avis défavorable qui
et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté
la bande mans 11 président kader et
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
un amendement qui vise à donner
finalement plus de poids encore à ce
fameux conseil scientifique sur lequel
repose beaucoup de légion du
gouvernement je vous rappelle que me
suis delfraissy le président qu'il a
toujours considéré qu'il était là pour
conseiller le gouvernement devant
décider à juste titre mais cette
décision doit s'appuyer sur une
information la plus large et la plus
rapide possible des français donc cet
amendement vise à ce que les avis du
comité scientifique soient rendues
publiques sans délai il nous est arrivé
de voir que des avis avait plus tarder
de deux trois quatre jours avant d'être
publiés si ce conseil à ce comité a une
importance parfois il n'est pas consulté
jeu un souvenir ému notamment sur
l'arrêt des compétitions sportives mais
dont tact en tout cas si les doigts de
consulter autant que ses avis soient
connues le plus vite possible de la part
des français
merci monsieur rapporteur nous avons
constaté
monsieur le ministre que plusieurs fois
les avis du comité scientifique ont été
retenus pendant plusieurs jours par le
gouvernement s'il s'était agi d'un
organe interne gouvernement on pourrait
le comprendre mais il a pris un statut
législatif dans les textes sur l'urgence
sanitaire et donc nous considérons que
il est plus démocratique d'assurer la
transparence et je salue cette
initiative de nos collègues du groupe
socialiste qui me paraît
particulièrement heureuse notre avis est
favorable le chat ministre je ne put
être je ne plus être qu'heureux que le
parlement souligne la transparence dont
le gouvernement a fait preuve très
heureux de cette initiative du conseil
scientifique je suis très heureux et je
remercie les membres du conseil
scientifique pour les appuis les avis
éclairés qui nous ont donné et je
m'enorgueillis d'avoir fait de la
transparence est la mise en ligne des
avis du conseil scientifique alors que
rien ne l'y obligeait encore une
constante alors il ya eu un délai
effectivement une fois parce qu'il ya eu
une erreur de mise en ligne qui a été
rectifiée je crois dans les huit minutes
après que
l' alerte nous ait été donné dans le cas
du débat sénatorial sinon ils ont été
mis et je crois pour la plupart en ligne
dans des délais plus que plus que
raisonnable cela dit j'ai aucune
difficulté à vous donner satisfaction
sur la nécessité qu'il soit mis en ligne
sans délai puisque et c'est encore une
fois une première dans la gestion d'une
crise sanitaire nous n'avons rien à
cacher et ce depuis le premier jour donc
c'est favorable
je vous remercie donc je mets au roa cet
amendement 11 avec deux avis favorables
commission gouvernement qui et pour qui
et contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
l'amendement 21 mai lendemain de bassar
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues par les
lois du 23 mars et du 11 mai 2020 le
législateur a institué un certain nombre
de dispositions pénales et répressives
en ces mesures visaient à garantir la
sécurité de nos concitoyens pendant la
crise sanitaire en sanctionnant le non
respect des règles édictées en vue de
contrer la pandémie notamment sur le
confinement ou sur l'application du port
du masque et des gestes par yale dans
les transports en commun et les lieux
publics
il est aujourd'hui proposée par l'alinéa
15 de l'article 1 de permettre au
premier ministre d'avoir recours à ces
dispositions
après le 10 juillet et la sortie de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
si une augmentation du nombre de cas de
covile 19 étaient à déplorer
les auteurs du présent amendement
dénonce la banalisation à laquelle
s'adonnent l'exécutive concernant ces
mesure coercitive et répressive
ces sanctions pénales ont été introduits
dans notre législation en raison de la
crise sanitaire
de telles mesures le sol est utilisé en
dehors du cadre dans lequel elles ont
été édictées présente à l'article l3132
6-1 du code de la santé publique
ces dispositions pénales n'ont pas
vocation à voir le champ d'application
élargie dans un état de droit
les mesures adoptées dans des
circonstances sanitaires et
sectionnelles ne peuvent devenir la
règle ainsi est il proposé par le
présent amendement de supprimer la linea
15 je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur l'avis
défavorable monsieur le président tout
de même quand il ya des règles il faut
des sanctions dont ceux qui ne les
respectent pas sinon il n'y a plus de
règle merci monsieur ministre
défavorables aussi donc je mets au voile
amendement 21 avec un double avis
défavorable qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
moment trois le président rock et puis
merci monsieur le président monsieur un
collègue la campagne des tests de
dépistage de 8,19 est une préoccupation
partagée par l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens mais peut-être encore plus
que chez ses doutes au maire dans les
territoires insulaires la suspension des
moyennes de transport les conséquences
beaucoup plus importantes qu'en
métropole
ce toutes les chaînes
d'approvisionnement la régulation les
saturation des hôpitaux y est plus
problématique encore la quarantaine la
sonatel alternative au test est
cependant très contraignante et pour y
pratiquer nuire à la vie économique
familiale de nos concitoyens d'outre-mer
qui dépendent grandement de nizon avec
la métropole est fortement ont été
observées dans les premières semaines de
campagne de tests aussi compte tenu de
l'importance qui est proposée par
collègues terrain d'entraînement saint
pierre et miquelon que celle ci fasse
l'objet d'un engagement gouvernementaux
plus important au niveau des catalans
merci monsieur rapporteur sur président
inquiet je ne crois pas aux vertus d'un
décret pour suppléer le manque de moyens
et les défauts d'organisation et je
crois que le mérite de cet amendement
est quand même de poser le problème de
la manière la plus claire
mais la solution qui la porte ne réglera
pas aussi je vais demander au ministre
ce qu'il compte entreprendre pour régler
cette difficulté il va nous le dire
et peut-être qu'il sera suffisamment
convaincants cher président roch et pour
que vous retiriez votre abonnement
merci monsieur ministre
sur l'amendement 3 pour moi la ville
l'amendement est satisfait monsieur le
sénateur je vous propose volontiers le
le retrait parce que vous souhaitez que
soient précisées par décret les
conditions dans lesquelles sont mises en
oeuvre les constatations médicales
préalable au placement à l'isolément
ça ne semble pas utile puisque la loi
encadre ces mesures d'isolement il
renvoie d'ores et déjà un décret pour
fixer ses conditions d'application
donc le décret déjà existants et ses
conditions prévues par par la même voie
merci président ok il est retiré ont
tiré merci nous passons amendement 26 du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre jose
retenter un amendement gouvernemental
quelque chose me dit que que celui ci
peut passer il s'agit de donner la
compétence au préfet de police pour
l'application des dispositions pour
l'île de france
ça fait écho incertain certains débats
puisque le préfet de police est à parier
sur les emprises ces trois aéroports
parisiens les attributions du
représentant de l'état en matière de
menace sanitaire d'état d'urgence
sanitaire merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur rapporteur vous avez convaincu
la commission monsieur le ministre
donc avis favorable donc je mets au
voile amendement 26 du gouvernement avec
un avis favorable de la commission qui
et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté je mets aux voix l'article
1er qui est pour l'article 1er qui et
contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté un article additionnel
après cet article le 14 c'est madame
artigalas
oui donc cet amendement je le défends
pour ma collègue sénatrice des de
martinique catherine conconne les
régions d'outre-mer ont diversement
étaient touchés par l'épidémie de du co2
coville 19le virgules le virus circule
encore fortement en guyane et à mayotte
alors qu'il a été relativement et par là
relativement épargné la martinique la
guadeloupe et la réunion
à ce jour les cas détectés sur ces trois
territoires sur sont uniquement des cas
importés
il n'y a pas de cas autochtone pour ces
territoires l'enjeu est donc de
permettre la reprise normale des
liaisons aériennes ainsi que le retour
progressif des touristes et des
ultramarins de l'hexagone qui rentrent
passer les grandes vacances dans leur
famille tout en maintenant des mesures
de contrôle sanitaire pour empêcher
l'importation du virus depuis le 9 juin
un dispositif expérimental a été mis en
place
il préconise pour chaque voyageur la
réalisation de tests virologiques dans
les 72 heures qui précèdent son départ
pour les autres maires si ce test est
négative le voyageur de respecter une
période de confinement de sept jours à
l'issue de laquelle il doit réaliser
notre test six secondes testées
négatives le voyageur peut se déplacer
librement
les voyageurs qui n'ont pas réalisé de
test avant le départ doivent effectuer
une quatorzaine strictes ces mesures de
certaines et de 14,9 vocation à
disparaître avec la fin de l'urgence
sanitaire et c'est tant mieux car elles
sont assez dissuasives comme l'a dit
notre collègue michel magras pour la
reprise du tourisme
il est néanmoins nécessaire de maintenir
un contrôle sanitaire pendant les
prochains mois sous la forme de tests
virologiques obligatoire pour les
personnes souhaitant se rendre en
outre-mer afin de permettre une reprise
du tourisme tout en protégeant la
population
il s'agit d'une demande très forte de
ces territoires
compte tenu de ces considérations le
présent amendement vise à maintenir la
possibilité donnée au premier ministre
jusqu'au 30 octobre de prendre un décret
pour imposer des tests virologiques aux
personnes souhaitant se rendre dans les
autres bars merci cher collègue monsieur
rapporteur de l'avis de la commission
puis je voudrais dire à notre
collègue sénatrice artigalas que en
réalité quand cet amendement a été
rédigé ses auteurs partait du principe
que l'arctique le premier allait être
supprimé mais il se trouve que dans
notre article mais qui vient au
contraire d'être adopté il y à un quarto
pour un 5ème alinéa qui dit en d'autres
termes certainement moins élégant avec
un style qui peut manquer de souffle par
rapport au texte de votre amendement la
même chose du coup on n'a plus besoin de
votre moment parce que nous sommes
d'accord et que nous venons d'adopter la
même règle c'est la raison pour laquelle
je vous demande de bien vouloir le
retirer sinon je donnerai un avis
défavorable mais c'est inutile de voter
contre un amendement avec lequel nous
sommes d'accord mais il ne faudrait pas
que ya un problème d'écriture de
l'ensemble de la loi parce qu'on aurait
voté deux fois la même chose à des
articles différents en des termes
différents ça créerait une confusion
merci monsieur nice et même avis madame
artigalas mais c'est vrai monsieur le
président de la commission des lois je
trouvais que l'amendement effectivement
été enfin été plus précis mais
effectivement et qu'il avait plus de
portée que ce que vous aviez laissées
dans l'article 1er mais bon je me range
à votre avis et je retirais cet
amendement merci reconnaît donc il est
retiré
on passe à l'article 1er bis avec une
prise de parole de fabien gay merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
cette loi organisant la sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire achemine doucement
la société vers un retour à la normale
en sortant des règles d'exception
sauf dans un domaine le droit du travail
en effet à l'occasion de la loi
établissant l'état d'urgence du 23 mars
dernier vous aviez fait adopter un
catalogue de mesures régressives pour
les salariés au prétexte de l'épidémie
de covile 19
ainsi vous avez autorisé les employeurs
d'imposer unilatéralement des jours de
congé aux salariés et aux fonctionnaires
autoriser les entreprises dit relevant
de secteurs particulièrement nécessaire
à la sécurité de la nation ou à la
continuité de la vie économique et
sociale et dont nous n'avons jamais vu
la liste à déroger au temps de travail
maximale europe aux hebdomadaires et au
repos dominical
depuis trois mois les entreprises
peuvent pleinement profité du
dérèglement du travail et exploiter
toujours plus et sans compensation les
travailleuses et les travailleurs
pourquoi le projet de loi organisant la
sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire ne
prévoit-il pas de retour à la normale
pour les droits des salariés
pourquoi d'en attendre fin décembre pour
établir le repos dominical et la liberté
des jours de repos hier vous nous disiez
que les dispositifs mis en place par le
gouvernement était justifiée par
l'urgence de la pandémie et de
l'impossibilité pour les entreprises de
travailler normalement
aujourd'hui vous nous dites que c'est la
reprise économique qui semble justifier
de remettre en cause les règles
essentielles de santé et de sécurité au
travail demain les risques d'une seconde
ou une troisième vague du coc vite 19
justifieront le maintien de ces
dispositifs d re dérogatoire temporaire
ainsi le gouvernement transformera les
dispositifs exceptionnels
un dispositif permanent en outre passant
largement les droits des salariés
pour l'ensemble de ces raisons nous
demandons que la sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire concerne aussi les
dérogations du droit du travail
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
nous passons à l'amendement 29 du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre nous
ne disons pas qu'il ne faudra pas à
porter en tout cas évalué l'article 31
31 et son implication dans la gestion
des crises sanitaires
nous considérons par contre qu'il est
vraiment beaucoup trop tôt pour le faire
en modifier la porte et en modifier les
paramètres modifier les contours même si
sa part de la volonté d'en renforcer par
endroits la capacité d'agir nous sommes
me semble extrêmement prématuré
nous aurons l'occasion de faire le bilan
de cette crise sanitaire des outils
juridiques législatifs utiliser
utilisable nous avons donné la date
d'avril au plus tard il faut quand même
un peu de temps de réflexion je ne crois
pas pour le coup c'est le gouvernement
qui est pris de court monsieur le
président par l'adoption en commission
un amendement qui vise à légiférer sur
un des articles les plus fondamentaux
dans ce qu'il permet de conférer des
pouvoirs dérogatoire dont on a vu la
porte est dans une situation inédite
comme celle que nous venons de traverser
je ne crois pas très sincèrement que
nous puissions pas l'un entre mise un
amendement à ce texte
donner une portée nouvelle à cet article
31 31 souhaitons le conserver en l'état
tout en nous engageant à ce qu'ils aient
une évaluation qui soit fait encore une
fois une réflexion collective sur les
modifications à apporter et monsieur
rapporteur oui je dois une explication
au ministre parce que nous aussi nous
travaillons par la mise en place d'une
commission denquête à faire le bilan de
cette crise sanitaire pour pouvoir
mettre en place les instruments qui nous
permettrait à l'avenir si de nouvelles
épidémies sur l'iss
et de nouvelles épidémies surgiront de
disposer d'instruments qui nous
permettrait de surmonter cette crise
sans porter atteinte trop grave aux
libertés individuelles et collectives et
sans entraîner par un confinement
généralisée des conséquences
dévastatrices sur le plan économique et
social
et c'est cette réflexion que nous devons
avoir les uns et les autres pour la
faire converger au sénat nous
instruisons pas de procès nous avons été
constructif pour donner au gouvernement
des moyens d'action dont il estimait
avoir besoin et traverser cette crise
alors pourquoi ne pas attendre monsieur
le ministre c'est ça la question que
vous me posez au fond et bien pour une
raison très simple si nous avions adopté
votre article 1er reprenant
textuellement trois dispositions
essentielles de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
vous auriez eu des moyens que nous
pensions être excessif mais qui aurait
été beaucoup plus important que ce que
nous vous donnons par l'article 1er que
nous venons d'adopter et nous a donc
paru nécessaire de ne pas baisser la
garde et de permettre au gouvernement
dans cette période de sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire est pas dans un an
d'utiliser un instrument juridique qui
s'est révélée
de l'aveu même du gouvernement comme du
point de vue du conseil d'état d'une
très grande fragilité
parce que cet article du code de la
santé publique de la france au entière
connaît par coeur aujourd'hui tant il a
été cité l'article l3132 1-1
il donne au ministre de la santé en
réalité des pleins pouvoirs
je pense que le législateur n'a pas
entendu vie donner de tels pouvoirs mais
comme vous avez dû décider le
confinement toutes affaires cessantes
avant même le vote de la loi
du 23 mars puisque le confinement date
du 16 mars
vous avez utilisé les dispositions de
cet article et je crois que s'il y avait
eu des recours contre les textes
réglementaires des arrêtés de simple
arrêté ministériel qui ont été pris sur
la base de cet article et qui
restreignait comme on l'a jamais vu en
france les libertés individuelles
vous vous seriez retrouvé très
probablement avec de multiples
annulation pour excès de pouvoir et du
coup nous nous sommes dit si le
gouvernement sort de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire mais que néanmoins compte tenu
de la persistance même localement de
l'épidémie il devait prendre un certain
nombre de mesures
cet instrument à la lumière de
l'expérience s'est révélé insuffisant et
par conséquent il faut le modifier
maintenant ce qui ne nous interdit pas
nous-mêmes sénat dans notre commission
denquête de proposer d'autres
dispositions dans quelques mois mais
c'est maintenant que vous pouvez avoir
besoin de recourir à cet article et cet
article est trop fragile
voilà la raison pour laquelle nous avons
adopté en commission cet article 1er bis
à que vous voulez supprimer et il nous
restons cohérents avec nous même en vous
disant que nous préférons conserver
notre article
tant pis si vous devrez ensuite à de
nous faire adopter des modifications
nous y sommes prêts
merci monsieur reporter donc je mets au
voile amendement 29 du gouvernement avec
un avis défavorable de la commission qui
et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adoptée jeu mais on voit
l'article 1er bis à quai pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
voilà vous avez pu suivre la séance hier
au sénat consacrée à la sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
les sénateurs ont donc modifié ce projet
de loi objectif restreindre les
prérogatives du gouvernement tout en lui
permettant de lutter contre l'épidémie
de e.coli 19 je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez retrouver toute l'actualité
parlementaire et tous les articles de
notre rédaction sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr c'est la fin de cette
émission
je souhaite une excellente journée